when dr. jess has called me a couple
months ago to consider speaking as a
wrap-up I think as people know in my
section I'm one of those I think by the
myers-briggs called the intj I'm
relatively introverted so coming up and
speaking here it does always make my
heart rate go above 100 but I'm glad
that we can't measure that yet and I
have to say this morning just sitting
and listening to I've had the pleasure
of listening to dr. Sullivan's talk
which I found is really inspiring a
couple months ago I'm listening to my
colleagues service chattery talk about
some of the work they do some of the
other initiatives that are going around
here is just I find really inspiring and
exciting and as I was talking with Amy
justice a couple its earlier you know I
have to say though I don't think that
five years ago that we would have the
same kind of audience and enthusiasm for
electronic media that we do today and
why that shift has happened i think is
something that is worth considering as
an audience and let me just give you an
example and then I'll kind of back into
I've actually taken seven pages of notes
this morning but I won't go through all
of them but I think there are some
important points to consider as we go
forward in this in this medium depending
on how you want to use it in each of you
are clearly using it in different ways
and there are challenges and
opportunities associated with each of
them so just a to kind of little tidbits
five years ago I got a call from an
editor at a major medical journal and
that editor asked me potentially if I
was interested in moving to to that city
and becoming a part of their journal as
part of editorial staff and I said I was
only interested in it if they considered
really sort of containing a more media
friendly component in the journal at
that time journals were still largely
what came through your mailbox that if
your dog didn't shoe it up you were
lucky that it survived online had still
really become something that was viewed
as secondary and I said you know a sort
of multimedia in terms of interactivity
even if it's you know it's not only
researchers but it's the patient
community at large is something where I
think the journals
going to be going I think it's a
presence that fill in the blank you want
to be and the editor said no and lo and
behold the major competitor of this
journal editor about two years later
launched a very very aggressive
multi-dimensional sort of media type of
interactivity on their journal and I
just thought you know I'm glad I didn't
move because i really love here but i
really think it was a lost opportunity
in terms of sort of what different forms
of media can do that can be accessible
not only to us as researchers but to
patients and the public at large because
i think part of the next step in terms
of what the next media conference is
going to be is how do you take tools are
you using and research products that you
are creating that are using media and
make it more accessible to a public and
the public to the public to people who
don't have kind of the level of
education that most people have in this
room so that was the first little piece
I wanted to throw out and and that's
really shifted I mean you look now at
the new england journal of medicine and
they have video conference lines they
have audio they have interactive
clinical correlations every week I'm
just astounded at kind of what they
offer that didn't even exist five years
ago and furthermore it wasn't something
that we as a culture thought we should
provide and that's been a shift now I'll
go back to my life this weekend or I'm a
general internist and I was on call from
my practice and I was in clinic on
Friday afternoon in Waterbury which is
with a largely underserved patient
population many of whom don't speak
English many of whom do not have homes
but interestingly almost all of them
have cell phones and you all know this
now because many of you use cell phones
in your work and all I know do they have
cell phones they have cell phones with
cameras on them so I'm sitting here
thinking how can I be more efficient in
my patient care and you can consider
thinking about opportunities using cell
phones and cameras as a way to really
work with high-risk patients what if we
videotaped every medical
team in a counseling session that you
had with your patients and that video
could be put on their digital on their
phone and they can take it home and
watch it as opposed to giving them a
form which never goes anywhere other
than into a bag so that was one thing I
thought about that i thought about
consistently as a provider i was also on
call this weekend for my clinic and i
have to say who do i get called from the
most besides the emergency room it's
visiting nurses visiting nurses who
basically call me they've had a patient
who's been discharged from the hospital
they have no idea what meds the patients
were on and are on now and even though
there's a really long w10 or a form they
don't really know and that's really sort
of i think what dr. Chaudry alluded at
today which was that media is really
underutilized in care transition points
and we're now technologically at a place
where you can five years ago media was
too expensive to do this you know you
didn't have you had much more issues
related to storage technology sighs and
and now you've got frankly everything is
digital you can put a terabyte of
material onto onto a drive for less than
fifty dollars so so why can't viene is
actually what are we videotape all
hospital discharges I mean we don't have
to videotape some of the more issues
related to sex i'm going to stay away
from that but but thinking about some of
these some of these moments in time
where the audience is largely just about
patient and provider or and and yet
there needs to be more people who need
to be able to see those interactions
that's where electronic media I think
really has a number of fantastic
opportunities that we as providers or
researchers could do so those are sort
of my ideas that I thought back there
today but there are other issues which
because since the topic top the title of
my talk is challenges and opportunities
that I think we should all consider as
we move forward and theme that I wrote
it down today why is electronic media
why are we here and why would electronic
media be different as opposed to let's
say a conference on just media
and health how are those two things
different and I think they are different
media when i started in media was very
much sort of traditional
bricks-and-mortar model people watched
television networks controlled what the
message was it was broadcast on the
screen in your home and it had a very
sort of set way of who controlled the
message and I think that's also similar
in some ways that's how it shifted in in
medicine as well who controls the
message who controls media has shifted
so one thing I think about that we have
in terms of the median out interactivity
now the media has a means in terms of
making basically your experience in
health care much more interactive
there's a porous pneus that media can
allow that often other current systems
don't offer our patients you see that
somewhat in electronic medical records
as a doctor from the v8 dr. McKenna's
talked about earlier this this morning
but it's mostly email so can potentially
you now change that so you have other
types of information that can patients
can interact with within systems that we
have the media isn't instantaneous
that's something that's changed in terms
of what healthcare can provide patients
it can be a for instance as a patient I
will still really like to be able to
access my lipid level next week have it
texted to me instantaneously that
current system doesn't exist even within
the Yale health plan as you know you
have to email your provider and it kind
of asked them gently for the result and
they might send it back to you but
generally you're waiting and yet most of
us in this room this morning have texted
someone we have gotten two or three
voicemails and so there's an
instantaneous component that I think we
have not yet sort of brought into what
we do in our research and educational
tools for patients why is that I think
some of it is in terms of what our skill
sets are we're not trained as media
maker
you know most usually when I go to
research a topic I go to PubMed and
that's a very different type of
information that's given to me as
opposed to let's say I'm a producer for
CNN and I want to create a program on
HIV education those type of skill sets
are very different and I think that's
learning those type of skill sets are
things that we're going to have to do is
we go forward other issues that I think
in terms of where and it's clear today
that people use the media as or aspects
of the media either to study different
patient populations or tools to engage
with patients at times in their life
when we don't have access to them so for
instance looking at high-risk behavior
most of us never have access to that in
our patient sort of traditional model of
it of an exam room you don't know how
how X behavior occurs so we create
technologies so that potentially we can
interact with them but i also think
there are places in the healthcare
system where we could consider using
media in ways that actually might make
us somewhat uncomfortable so consider
how actually we trained physicians and
how patients interact with physicians
most of how we even trained surgeons
internists none of it is measured we
don't know anything prospectively about
performance you can consider videotaping
or audio taping all of our informed
consent with our patients when I mention
that usually people get somewhat
concerned but but this is sort of an
area where I think the media is going to
move because because it's pretty much
it's so portable for patients other
areas in terms of and this raises whole
issues of privacy and ownership which I
know dr. Carol talked about today who
owns products that you make but actually
who owned patients data who ain't
patients experiences up until now for
the most part we've assumed we've owned
it we've assumed how we disseminate this
and how we transmit this but that's
changing if you look at there was a
piece that time magazine wrote on Mayo
Clinic
two years ago were actually they had
done a study on patients with celiac
disease and rather than traditional
mortar and bricks method whereas journal
publishes study releases it to media
first for a week media has a week to
sort of chew on it media calls you
researcher interviews you and hopefully
you end up on cover of New York Times or
NPR or macneil/lehrer and you know then
then your employer is very happy with
you so what male did actually was they
release for study findings to their
patients who participated in the trail
first and then and then they released it
to the media so you're beginning to see
organizations using media as a way to
share information with patients I think
in the next five years that is very
interesting very quite controversial and
professor Adel ssin this morning sort of
stole my Thunder because he talked about
patients like me which i think is one of
the the the most interesting health
sites and use of media by patients that
is not only controversial but it's quite
innovative and for those of you don't
who knows about patients like me okay I
would for all of you i would spend just
10 or 15 minutes you're stuck in an
airport you're delayed you have nothing
else to do it was started back in 2004
is interesting how it got started by
three brothers who were MIT engineers
their oldest brother had ALS and they
anybody who's ever spent any time with
anyone has ALS knows pretty quickly
because there are absolutely no
therapies often patients will go to the
Internet to really come to look on look
for therapies look for support and I
think that's what patients often do
because they feel so isolated but they
created a website for patient patience
with neurological disorders and unlike
many other websites patients often will
submit their names they'll submit their
age they'll submit their symptoms and
often and and and then they can compare
different disease symptoms with
different types of drugs so a patient
with depression let's say who has not
responded to prozac or celexa can find
that
they share there are certain symptoms
that may be lexapro works better for
them and they have I think as of last
count over a hundred thousand registered
users first it was mostly neurological
disorders and now they've moved to other
disorders word the therapies are sort of
less defined and it's very interactive
patients are very comfortable with being
exposed they're much more interested
transparency and it makes researchers
very nervous not surprisingly as you can
imagine potentially you're thinking
about how can patients be exploited with
this and who's doing all the data mining
that's another question it's mostly
Pharma so and page looks me a sort of is
not the only type of sort of electronic
media patient and powered types of
websites you pick some of the rare
disease conditions brain tumors diabetes
many of the stigmatized conditions you
can find that all online and so I think
these are some of the next steps and
questions we as researchers what if you
have patients who want more ownership in
their day in there in the research
process if they're more comfortable with
transparency even if you verbalize being
aware of the risks how much of the role
should they play in their care and and
media is a place where you begin to see
that interactivity happen more than
let's say just the chart the chart is
largely retrospective it's largely
text-based it's largely one-dimensional
and the media allows you to change that
interaction and because that moves up
into more than one two dimension I think
it produces a lot of discomfort the
other piece too is what do you do with
all this you know it's great if you have
a terabyte worth of video material or
you have hundreds of hours of audio tape
material but you know where are you
going to store it you know who's going
to analyze it any time you look at type
of media information it's very messy and
and what we've done for now for the most
part we sort of parked it into
continuous quality improvement which
men's means that if there's something
that we video tape or a record that
makes us potentially uncomfortable
meaning i eat error or not so a
professional behavior we just erase it
and which is true it's what a lot of the
trauma services do they just erase the
tape after a week but now digital has
made it much harder to erase so so so
what do you do with these issues of
potential exposure of behavior on the
part of either provider or patient where
it's not so clear it's about sort of the
best possible care so so these are some
of the issues that I kind of chew around
in my head and think about I think it's
fabulous that we're using media as we go
forward I think there are more ways that
we can use media that will involve
patients and I think particularly as the
technology evolves just as an example a
high def video camera and high def up
until now was largely what Hollywood
used a high def video camera is less
than seven hundred dollars you can buy a
little camera you can put on your head
if you're like a mountain biker for less
than one hundred and fifty dollars so
you have you really have a compression
of what is accessible to the public and
so I think that's really exciting but I
think it I think there are issues that
we have not really yet to just say one
more example because I think this is
really interesting when I'll stop this
appeared on ABC News in December of this
year there was a couple in a hospital in
Pennsylvania who had wanted to videotape
their the delivery of their fifth child
in the hospital they wanted to route to
sort of record this event as something
for posterity and and the hospital
basically said no the hospital said they
could start videotaping five minutes
after the Apgar scores have been
collected and I'm has created a huge
firestorm of controversy as you can
imagine Brian Williams did a story on it
and then of course if you look on the
NBC website that work hundreds and
hundreds of responses and it's and so
again sort of sort of sort of tip toes
into the issue of who owns media who
owns the patients experience if
information that relates to a patient's
experience as viewed as research how
should that be disseminated so I don't I
don't have the answers to all of these
but I think these are sort of issues
that we need to wrestle with as we go
forward as a physician would I be
comfortably being videotaped on all my
hospital rounds I don't know I don't
know I don't know about that but I think
those days are coming because technology
is portable and smaller